4 저는 시장은 어떻게 됐어요
빼앗아 잘 지냈습니다 임신 약
제가 아주 정치 했어요
오늘이 에 축구가 91 도장 마지막 날인데 마님은 됩니다
과정 양 때가 아 주점 추
줄거운 에 기본이요 아주 증가 3
에 어 너른 제가 음 집처럼 과 같이 거 로서 바로
에 그 우리 해외 왜 발이 9
4 집사람과 같이 걸 불 찍어 볼게요
제 4 해몽 아 그러나 박쥐가 음
절대로 받으시 그 후 보건부 에 계속 그 하고 싶습니다
퍼 살아봤자 만약에 질문이 있으면 으 계속 물어 보세요
계속 그 저한테 항거가 왜 이런거 같아요
뭐로 물어봐 드네요 물로 보다보다 물어보자
4 srt 물어보다 때 이렇게 아 아 케첩 땅에 아물어 구야
예 에 자 꿈 제가 그 한국어
음 2 3 이해 에 하고
그러나 냐 제가 음
뭐 예
저녁 제가 에 보기 10
자신 없어요 차안에
제가 에 가끔 외국어 공부할 앞에
제가 에 더 그 반영 저 그 맹 제가 이에
같은 것은 그 신염 해야 합니다
그러나 같이 아내 에 제 저의 생각에 나 많은 사람들이 에 그 똑같이 고
그 에
감겨 있습니다 제가 이 같은 그런 그러면 제가 자 싱겁지 다시 한번 거
거 물어 에
므로 벗으 물로
쏠게요 볼게요 4 5 100
네 제가 했는데 4 제가 그 짓 앤
에 독해 거의 이에
에 제가 그 90 으 그 10일 동안
토해 아주 그 그
에 요청이 얘기할 수 없어요 그러나 에 그 한국어 대해서 그 형 미 4
자시 자시 저희 타신 과장
자 아 그 중 가 않고 있
뭘요 empas 5 4 정말 자신감이 증가 했어요
4 진짜 강좌 차신 감히 에 뿐 아니라 그 형 니 용리 이 낸 해명 맥
에 제가 그 영어로 모멘텀 모멘텀 5 에 내셔야 적용할 에
습성은 씨도 영어 에 불어 에 아주 오류창이 얘 지금 에 알 수 있습니다
그러나
에 지적 한테 요 머리 5 어 어려워 로 그
맞아요 네 제가 중국어
음 할 때 되게 어려워 없다고
말씀드렸잖아요 4
처음에 저 죽어 배울 때 너무 자신이 없어서
흥미도 없었어요 4 에 똑같은 경우에요 4
내 이렇게 그 시작 했고 집에 그 제향 네메시스
좀 처함 차후 하는 아주 강할 총 있으니 내 하자 그 모멘트 먹지 그
없이 지 이제 자신감도 없어요
4 그러나 계속 해야 합니다
막 아 진짜 동의합니다
4 4 어떤 어떤 정도 어떤 정도
까지 그 도작
에 하면 내외
에 뭐 도 수요 빠져 하자 일정한 금액 r 까진
가야되요 네 네 지금 제가 그 한국어 대해서 그 간접 가지고 있습니다 응
개혁 수사관이 포함한
절대로 제가 에 잔해
에 더 토 에 그 유 장의 에 아 그 얘기 하 아 아 하우스 그 강용수
가능성이 있어요 를 마다라
4 나중에 한국어 더 자라면 또 그 때 녹음 해요
4 예 극상학생회 에 지금 에 어느 이렇게 텐데 제가 그 에
지금 에 써 l 씨와 그 얘길 가능
그 목적이 그
저의 미디어 어 보는 사람들의
에 4 저의 제 에
양상 하는 그 정독 예 거의 거인은 4
배급 업장이 짜내 그러나 같이 자신에게
괜찮아요 제가 별로 에
별로 체크 팩 으 음
아리스의 킬 수 없지 그 음 완벽 이 이야기 에 하려고 그 생각 전혀
없어요
네 아주 좋아야 살아가게 세야 4
전염 4 제가 재계 만족하고 있습니다
4 에 음 만
다른 에
것 공부 한테 간에 이 사람들의
에
3 에 소상 예 4 제가
지구 끝이 자신에게 자신의 목적이 에 으러 그 근무
하구요 달라 사람들이 에 하루씩 폴더 show
다른 사람의
시산 지성 씨 내 시상 신경 쓸 필요 옥사 4 필요 없어요
이제 자자 이렇게 같구 군부 그 에 그 계속 그 에
야 기 때문에 그 자신감
나 2 중요합니다 에
그렇기 때문에 제가 가 꿈
자신에게 에
자신에게 그
자 신검 만족함 예 있다면
4 봤냐 저도 초 4 초 쏩니다
별로 가량 사람들이 아스 아이와 애착 하시네요
b 없습니다 맞아요 그리고 스탭으로 씨가 케 장기적으로 언어 공부를
하시잖아요 으
예 그게 정말 좋은 단어인 것 같아요
예 4 4 저한테 묵어 로 음 이번 주말에 뭐 하셨는지 얘기해줄 수
있어요
얘기 2 아래 으
뭐 하셨어요 뭐 하셨어요 뭐
예 무슨 이래 하셨어요 아 에 무슨 일이 이제 이렇게 주말에 우리가 해에
그 얘기 해 에 하루에 그 약속 끼 있었었다 4
제가 에 유럽 어쩌구 1호
이 1호 이쪽 번에 이쪽 어렵다 아서가
아 아 잊어버렸어요 4일 벌이도 떴네요 아 괜찮아 그냥
주말을 잘 보냈는지
주말에 뭐 가족들이랑 시간을 보냈고 산책도 하고 왜 뭔가 하고 4
운동 더 하고 곳에 황이 해주세요 4
한국가서 흠 누나 하앙 걸어 한국으로 사실 엄지가
이런 에 체크
이렇게 그 10일 동안 예 에 초 에 좀 [ __ ] 3점 방 겸 한 벌 사
좀 탁 천단 첨 정상 정말 아 정말
에 그 당시 제가 많이 공부했습니다
매일 외에 에 4 3 14시간 공부 했었다
그러나 후에 이유를 가지 에 집사람과 가 짓고 여행도 하고
에 그렇죠 에 그리고
에 그 러시아 olin 하러 여러가지 5 플레이 야 예상 학원에서
여러가지 그 인터넷 에서 이 이거 듣고 해 급하고
에 아마도 그 음
후방에서 에 메이 한식 한지
앉지 즉 4 도 라 마
그러나 괜찮습니다 괜찮아요 그 모멘텀 했다 하고 몽 진짜 잡았어요
예 그러나 즉 그 내가 지금 제가 하는 그 부하 하던 것은 그
빈말 영아의 보드 탔어요
예 각 에피소드는
에 40분 50분 아주 큰 에 뒤 이 기름 에 그랬어
왜냐하면 에 우리 링크에서 그 그 길 써서 아주 에 여기서 수 oq 배
써니 내려야 예
는게 아요 늘려라 에 그렇기 때문에 지금 제가 우리 w 에 카메라로 내게
꼭 그 길을 은 애써 뭐
예
3 도에 1
음 적게 에 해주셔서 그 제가 부탁했어요 예 뭐 물어 떴어요 물어봤어요
내가 서 부탁했어요 내가 사용했어요
4 에 제가 음 반드시 그 그 13
그 10쌍 에피소드는 에 공부하고 쉽습니다
내가 깎을 때 쓴 40분 50도 그 내 지금 에 10분 쪼쪼 그 처음
레슨 됩니다
4 타인의 그렇기 때문에 공부하니 에 쉬게 됩니다
으 수레로 그 54 53
에피소드는 에 응 아마도 음
200 200개 애써 으 으 아 네 제가 그 계속 그 공부하면 제가 그
그 근대 끝나면
내 [ __ ]이 저의 한국어 수정아 에 얀 새 에 하겠습니다
패킷 에 할게요 4 ok 감사합니다
여러가지 행했습니다 예 여러가지 즐겁게 거의 가 이야기 에
해외 주소 감싸네
아 저도 털뭉치가 와봐 아 예 아 예
다시한번 으
mscs 예 뻐
벌어져요 왜 그 알겠소
아야 좀 역시 보고도 투 알려 줘 어 씨 보정 4 2 1 발전돼
한 번 무서 거야